une dernière activité avant de se
quitter
pendant toute une semaine ces jeunes du
secondaire et ses chercheurs de
l'université du québec à trois-rivières
ont fait équipe dans le cadre du
programme chercheurs de demain
le principe de la science le le pourquoi
la science église c'est de pouvoir la
communiquer c'est de découvrir les ans
ou de communiquer et de rendre
accessible que ce soit une personne de
67 ans comme une personne de 7 ans et en
ce cas là de saison
le programme a été initié par deux
étudiantes de l'iut air dont michel
boivin c'est sa propre participation à
une activité semblable qui l'a inspiré
ça prépare la relève
puis à chaque professeur qu'on discute
c'est difficile de trouver de la relève
des jeunes passionnés puis souvent ils y
ont recours à recrutement à
l'international
les adolescents de quatre écoles
secondaires de la région ont répondu à
l'appel
ils ont pu participer toute la semaine
aux recherches de leur mentor moi j'ai
sauté sur l'occasion le je me suis dit
let's go seulement dans d'explorer une
exploration unique pour ce jeune
passionné qui a pu manipuler des
microscopes autrement inaccessibles
c'est très bon énormément d'informations
maintenant mais c'est tellement
enrichissant pixcom qu'athènes se
mettent au pot limit enrichissant aussi
pour les chercheurs qui ont appris de
leurs jeunes stagiaires
on est souvent un peu reclus fameux on
travaille beaucoup dans le livre donc on
a peut-être une vision les personnes qui
nous ont appris et le fait d'avoir une
vision aussi fraîche d'une personne qui
qui forcément n'est pas aussi autant
sortie d'un moule comme nous c'est très
enrichissant pour nos cibles très très
enrichissant une première expérience
couronnée de succès les organisatrices
songe déjà à une seconde édition
mais là c'est clairement pas ici pascal
langlois radio canada trois rivières